yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
if you're an avid Easter Egg hunter like
me then prefer for a full-on geek gasm
as Captain America Civil War has doodles
to keep you entertained in this video
I'm going to run through all the Easter
eggs references and cameos I spotted in
the movie and of course I'd love to hear
about any others you notice too just
before that though I've got an exciting
giveaway thanks to DK so if you'd like a
chance to win this amazing Captain
America the ultimate guides the First
Avenger hardback book pack with tons of
cool info and images about caps 75 year
history and Marvel Comics as well as an
intro from Stanley himself then make
sure you subscribe and leave a comment
on this video about your favorite Easter
Egg from the movie for more ways to
enter click the gleam link in the video
description below and remember there are
spoilers ahead so if you want to avoid
those you can watch my spoiler free
review right here well though the movie
isn't a direct adaptation of Marvel
Civil War comic book series there are
some cool visual AR Marge's two iconic
covers and pages from the comics this
image of Iron Man blasting against
Captain America's shield comes in the
final issue of the Maine Civil War
series and when Captain America smashes
Iron Man's mask and looks like he's
about to finish off Tony Stark it's
incredibly similar to a moment from the
final battle between cap and Iron Man in
the comic books and during that final
fight scene Captain America's line to
Tony I could do this all day
echoes the same words who said while
fighting off a boolean and Ally and
Captain America the First Avenger and
again to red skull at the end of the
same movie also in that scene there's a
fresh hint that Bucky could one day take
up Captain America's mantle in the
movies as he does in the comics when cap
and Bucky pass the shield back and
forwards to each other as they batter
Iron Man with it there's already been a
nod to Bucky becoming Captain America in
each Captain America movie so far in the
first movie Bucky picks up cap shield
while they're fighting on the train
carrying Zola and in the Winter Soldier
Bucky grabs the shield when Rogers is
chasing him after Bucky shot Nick Fury
in this movie stairway fight scene you
can also see the influence of Gareth
Evans the raid action movies which also
influenced Marvel's daredevil on Netflix
the MCU czar Marsh to star wars arm loss
that started in phase 2 continues
interface
three with Bucky losing his metal arm
when Iron Man's reactor blasts it off in
that final fight scene when Tony Stark
calls Bucky Manchurian Candidate it's a
reference to the novel and film of the
same name about a man who's brainwashed
into becoming an assassin although Tony
Stark has a history of being grabbed by
the throat in Marvel's movies this time
he appears to escape with Falcon black
widow cap black panther and maria stark
all getting throttled by Bucky Barnes
instead oh and black panther almost got
to grab the his throat with his claws
until Scarlet Witch stepped in the cell
that book is held at is labeled d23 a
hidden reference to Disney's official
fan club d23 with 23 referencing the
Year 1923 that Walt Disney founded the
Walt Disney Company the activation codes
that Zemo uses to trigger Bucky have
some cool hidden references to the
numbers 1 9 and 17 form the year 1917
which is when Bucky Barnes was born
according to museum exhibit in the
winter soldiers post-credit scene
freight car is likely a reference to the
train freight car that Bucky fell from
in Captain America the First Avenger and
homecoming is a nod to the title of
spider-man's 2017 solo movie and the
word daybreak is likely a sneaky
reference to the TV show community
daybreak being a jazz melody which
featured in multiple episodes of the
show both Civil War directors Anthony
and Joe Russo directed and produced
numerous episodes of the comedy series
by the way there's another nod to
community in the cameo by Jim rash who
played Dean Pelton in the TV show in
civil war rushes the MIT liaison who
tries to get funding from Tony Stark for
his self cooking hot dog idea the
mission report date that zimos hunting
for December 16 1991 references the day
that Bucky assassinated Howard and Maria
Stark
with the news report we see in Captain
America the Winter Soldier being
published the very next day
coincidentally 16th of December 1991 is
also where Marvel published its very
first annual report to shareholders
which was actually in the form of a
comic book and curiously the movies
working title Sputnik is a clever Easter
Egg to what happens to Bucky at the very
end of the film in the comics Sputnik is
a safe word that the Russians implanted
in Bucky as a safety mechanism to shut
him down in case he went crazy in the
post-credits Bucky is shut down again
when he volunteers to be frozen until
someone can figure out how to room
with his Hydra programming Berkey
getting frozen in Wakanda also recalls
the flashback scene in the Winter
Soldier where Zola orders Bucky to be
put on ice and it's also a nod to the
Captain America comics where the Soviet
general Vasily Karpov decides to put
Bucky back into cryostasis while they
figure out what to do with him that same
Russian general Vasily Karpov from the
comics appears in the movie is the Hydra
agent who's emo drowns in Cleveland and
if you wondering what Karpov was doing
hanging out in Cleveland it's probably a
little tribute to the Ohio City in which
civil war directors Anthony and Joe
Russo grew up when cap pulls Bucky out
of the water after their helicopter
battle it's a nice reversal of the way
that Bucky pulled cap out of the water
after their battle on the Helicarrier at
the end of the Winter Soldier after his
return from the Winter Soldier movie
Brock rumlow references the battle at
the Triskelion when he accuses Captain
America of dropping a building on his
face to hide his burned and scarred face
rumlow returns masked and with his
trademark crossbones uniform and
weaponized gauntlets at the villain
house in the comics Vulcan sidekick
drone red wing is the emcee used version
of the real Falcon Red Wing from the
comics who Sam Wilson communicated with
telepathically in the movie that
telepathic link has been replaced with a
tech communications interface and
there's a couple more comic-book Falcon
Easter eggs in the movie - it's a cove
Iroquois which were approved by 117
countries reference Captain America
issue 117 which was Falken and Red Wings
first appearance in the series at the
airport one of the walkways is labeled
134 an Easter Egg - Captain America vol
wallet issue 134 when Sam Wilson
officially teamed up with cap and the
comic series was renamed Captain America
and the Falcon for over 80 issues and
the airport fight scene as a whole is
chock-full of Easter eggs when I'm man
asks Hawkeye about being retired and
playing golf
it's a funny wink to the what if comic
series were Hawkeye briefly took up golf
Rozlyn archery and the joke about
Hawkeye missing when he shoots the iron
man is also a nod to the Hawkeye blind
spot comics where Hawkeye shoots and
misses a gang of villains
Hawkeye shooting ant-man from his arrow
references Avengers number 223 where
Hawkeye shot ant-man from his arrow and
a fight against taskmaster
the fantastic scene when Scott Lang
transforms into giant man
is a nod to the time hank pym
transformed into giant man for the first
time in the comics and the hilarious
Star Wars joke by spider-man when he
takes down giant man by looping webbing
around his legs
of course references the Empire Strikes
Back movie when the Rebel Alliance used
tow cables to entangle and defeat an
8080 and giant man swatting at the
superheroes flying around his head I
shaded the Godzilla and King Kong movies
about it
spider-man nabbing cap shield at the
airport with his webbing as an Easter
Egg to the time he did that in the Civil
War series and at the end of the fight
when Peter Parker is partially a mast
it's a little nod to how spider-man took
off his mask to reveal his identity in
the Civil War comics and when spider-man
webs Captain America's legs and says
that Tony told him to do it it's a
little acknowledgement by the Russos of
criticism at the way gunman in the
Winter Soldier movie kept on shooting at
cap shield rather than trying to take
out his legs during the fight cap
smashes a walkway so that it falls onto
spider-man who has to use all this
strength to hold it up which is a nicer
March to the moment in the amazing
spider-man comics when Spiderman lifted
tons of steel that fell on him while
fighting Doctor Octopus and with
spider-man making his debut in the MCU
there's a stack more references and
easter eggs
Spidey's web shooters for example our
mechanical invention of his own rather
than the organic shoot as we saw in the
first vitamin trilogy spider-man's
origin gets just a brief reference when
Peter Parker says to Tony Stark when
whatever happened happened and is a
cryptic allusion to a possible tragedy
involving Uncle Ben when Peter Parker
says when you can do what you do and you
don't and then bad things happen it's on
you there's also a hint to the famous
spider-man phrase with great power comes
great responsibility
when Peter mentions that even though
he'd love to play football now that he
has his powers he shouldn't because he
couldn't before when Peter says to Tony
about the YouTube videos you've seen a
spider-man that it's all fake and done
on a computer it's a reference to the
fake spider-man post-credits scene for
Avengers age of Ultron that went viral
on YouTube and when Tony Stark's is
about aren't they it's so hard for me to
believe she's someone's arms and Marisa
Tomei replies that we come in all shapes
and sizes it's a reference to the
previous movie and comic book
incarnations of aren't they as well as
repulsed the backlash over to May being
cast in the role
early in May flirting with each other is
another reference to Robert Downey jr.
and Marisa Tomei his real-life
relationship in the 90s and also to
their on-screen relationship in the
rom-com only you by the way they also
starred in the biopic Chaplin together
and later back at Peter Parker's
apartment in the post-credits scene art
may ask Peter about the fight he got
into and if it's Steve from 12c which
could be a little Easter egg - the price
of the first spider-man comic which cost
12 cents during that post credits scene
we also get to see a new piece of tech
that Peter discovers while fiddling with
a shooter around his wrist the device
which projects a very cool Spidey symbol
onto the ceiling is very much like the
spider signal that spider-man has
attached to his belt in the comics and
it seems likely that this is some new
tech designed by Tony Stark Iron Man
himself also has some cool upgraded tech
for example his portable gauntlet which
and falls out of his watch is a similar
example to the miniaturization of his
whole suit which we saw in Iron Man 2
Maria Starks appearance during Tony's
September foundation speech at MIT where
he studied as a young man is likely a
nod to the Maria Stark Foundation set up
in the comics during the scene at MIT
when the young Tony Stark mentions the
Pentagon is a callback to the Avengers
age of Ultron when Tony said he'd hacked
into the Pentagon as a dare at high
school the grieving mother Miriam who
lost her son in sokovia and who
confronts Tony Stark and proves to be
the catalyst for him to support the
Satomura cords is based on the character
Miriam sharp from the comics who
publicly confronted Tony Stark about her
son he was killed in the Stamford
explosion alfre woodard the actress who
plays the mother is also set to play
Maria Dillard in Marvel's upcoming Luke
Cage series on Netflix by the way the
name of her dead son Charlie Spencer is
actually a nod to Robert Downey jr. as
role as Charles Spencer Chaplin in the
1992 biopic Chaplin and Tony Stark's
comment that Charlie Spencer didn't go
to Vegas or Fort Lauderdale which I do
is a reference to the first iron man
movie where Tony spends his time
gambling at the casino while he should
be receiving an award and to Iron Man 3
which filmed in the Fort Lauderdale area
when Tony goes to visit the Avengers who
are locked up in the raft
click bottom cause Tony Stark the
futurist and not the various times that
Ironman is referred to himself as a
teacher in the comics Tony Stark's is
about the prison
I didn't know they put you in some
floating Supermax ocean pokey this place
is for maniacs which is a reference to
the raft prison from the comics based on
Rikers Island and which housed some of
the worst supervillains from the Marvel
Universe Scott Lang also blamed Tony at
the raft saying that light Pym said you
can never trust a stark the callback to
the ant-man movie when Hank Pym
explained to Scott how he spent half his
life trying to keep his technology out
of the hands of a star and when Tony
Stark asks who are you Scott replies
come on man a funny echo from guardians
of the galaxy when star-lord was also
frustrated that chorus didn't know who
he was by the way Tony Stark's
electromagnetic headache is a not the
time in the Iron Man comics when Rhodey
donned the Iron Man costume and suffered
from headaches because the suit had been
tailored to match Tony Stark's brain
waves and when Tony is helping Rhodes
get back the use of his legs at the end
of the movie it's a reference to the
comics when Tony Stark built new bionic
limbs for war machine after he'd lost
him in a terrorist attack hyneman's AI
interface Friday he replaced Jarvis
after he became the vision in age of
Ultron returns with Tony saying he
imagined her as a redhead a little nod
to both the invincible Iron Man comics
in which she appeared as a redhead and
also to Pepper Potts
speaking of Pepper Potts her absence
from the movie is referenced twice once
at MIT and again when Tony explains to
Steve Rogers that Tony and Pepper have
taken a break as a couple which is a
possible reference of Gwyneth Paltrow's
marvel contract being at an end despite
rumors of our having filmed something
with Civil War two other civil war
absent ease thaw and Donna also get a
mention when Secretary of State Ross
asked the Avengers if they can explain
where these two superheroes are right
now the romantic relationship between
Scarlet Witch and vision in the comics
has hinted at a little more in the
scenes between the two in this movie in
particular the paprika cooking seem
there's also a vision Easter Egg when we
see him contemplating a chessboard in
the movie and a March the 1971 Avengers
cover where vision is analyzing a chess
opening and both characters powers from
the comics get a little more screen time
in civil war with vision altering his
density and firing optic blast from his
infinity stone scarlet witch's energy
manipulation is also much enhanced and
she can even power vision down through
multiple levels of a building by the way
Hawk eyes motivational mini speech the
Scarlet Witch at The Avengers Academy
the words you wanna mope you go to high
school wanna make amends
get off your ass is a callback to his
motivational speech to her during the
Battle of sokovia in Avengers age of
Ultron it's Sharon Carter's eulogy at
Peggy Carter's funeral that helps Steve
Rogers convince himself that he's right
to oppose the sokovia accords Sharon's
words about how it's your duty to plant
yourself like a tree and say no you move
for a nod to Captain America's speech to
Peter Parker in the Civil War comics
which use the same words and likewise it
was this speech in the comics by cap
which helped convince spider-man to swap
sides from being pro registration
Society with Captain America the romance
between Steve Rogers and Sharon Carter
that was hinted at in the Winter Soldier
develops into a kiss between the two in
civil war and caps words about the kiss
being late there's a little call back to
his description of himself as the
world's leading authority on waiting too
long in Avengers age of Ultron and of
course it's also a nod to his
relationship with Peggy Carter the agent
Carter TV series also gets a subtle
reference when cap and Bucky reminiscing
about trying to win a stuffed bear for a
girl named Dolores or Doss at Rockaway
Beach
Dottie Underwood is a Soviet assassin on
agent Carter who trained at the red
broom Academy where Black Widow also
trained Black Widows complicated spy
background gets referenced by iron man
when he snidely says to her it must be
hard to shake the double agent thing
sticks in the DNA after she lets Captain
America escape despite being on Team
Iron Man iron man's words are also a nod
to the ultimate series where Black Widow
tells her boyfriend Tony Stark that he
shouldn't be shocked at the former
Russian spy turned out to be the traitor
they've been looking for
speaking of Black Widow she has a run-in
with Black Panther security chief played
by German actress Florence kizomba the
security chief is likely one of black
panthers or female bodyguards called the
Dora Malaysia in the comics and she
orders Black Widow to move or you will
be moved this verbal confrontation is an
odds the time in the comics when Black
Widow was beaten by a group of Dora
Malaysia
Black Panthers costume can reflect
machine-gun bullets thanks to the
vibranium which is woven into his suit
black panther scratching cap shield with
his vibranium claws as a visual nod to
the Captain America annual cover which
showed Wolverine slamming his claws into
the first Avengers like
shield and there are more teasers to the
upcoming Black Panther movie ever at Kay
Ross the US government official played
by Martin Freeman has a small role in
civil war in the comics his job is to
liaise with foreign diplomats in
particular to Charla from work and ER
the mid-credits scene with Bucky being
treated at an advanced Medical Center
reflects the fact that in the Marvel
Comics work anda is a wealthy and
technologically advanced nation and the
huge black panther statue revealed and
Misty jungle location is intriguing peek
at work and ER in the MCU the airport
battle which takes place at Leipzig
Airport is a nod to Baron Helmut zimos
birthplace in the comics in Leipzig
Germany and when Zemo says to Captain
America there's a bit of green in the
blue of your eyes
how nice to find a floor it's a
reference to zimos Nazi background in
the comics the two days that it took the
Zemo to find the bodies of his wife and
child whereas the two days that Wanda
and Pietro Maximoff waited in the rubble
of a building expecting stocks bomb to
go off an Avengers age of Ultron and
with zero still alive at the end of
Captain America Civil War and the
villain ulysses klaw introduced in age
of Ultron there's a hint we might get
see most masters of evil in future
movies by the way this dacovian
killsquad echo scorpion zero used to run
could be a nod to the Marvel villain
scorpion he was also a member of the
Masters of evil Danny gets a fantastic
cameo delivering a FedEx parcel from
Steve Rogers to certain Tony stank which
road he makes sure Tony won't ever
forget this isn't Lee's first cameo as a
postal worker though in the 2005
Fantastic Four movie Lee appeared as
mailman Willie Lumpkin from the comic
books welcoming the Fantastic Four back
to the Baxter building
talking of cameos director Joe Russo has
a cameo as dr. Theo Prasad who Zemo
Kills leaving the body in his hotel room
bath Joe Russo also played dr. fine and
Captain America the Winter Soldier and
he's credited in both films under the
alias gogi Agbo by the way the name Theo
Broussard is likely and not to produce a
Steven Broussard whose executive
producer on Doctor Strange and was also
producer on Captain America the First
Avenger Iron Man 3 and the Incredible
Hulk and Russo the wife of director
Anthony Reese
is the voice of demos wife here we hear
on demos voicemail and Chris Evans
assistant Josh Peck cameo the gsg-9 task
force gunner while his stand-in from age
of Ultron and the Winter Soldier
Brent McGee also cameos as a gsg-9 task
force pilot and Damian Poitier who
played Thanos on the Avengers post
credit scene cameos as one of crossbones
mercs by the way the main cast credits
which appear before the mid-credits
scene in Wakanda include some cool art
work with thematic shadows that relate
to the characters Chris Evans is a
Captain America shield Tom Holland has a
spider's web for spider-man Jeremy
Renner has arrows for Hawkeye chadwick
boseman has a pattern from his black
panther suit Emily VanCamp has a number
13 for agent 13 Paul Rudd has the Pym
technology symbol for ant-man and frank
grillo gets a large X for crossbones
so guys what are the easter eggs and
references did you spot in Captain
America Civil War and which was your
favorite don't forget to comment and
subscribe for a chance to win this
Captain America the ultimate guide to
the First Avenger hardback book for more
ways to enter the giveaway check out the
gleam link in the video description
below if you enjoyed this video I've got
loads more Captain America Civil War
videos in this playlist here including
interviews post credits spider-man
videos my review and more thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers